can you try to i know it's really
difficult can you try to
talk through what's actually being
visualized in your head
is there
is there a visual component yeah no i
just visualize the board i mean the
board isn't as in as in my head
two-dimensional my interpretation is
that it's it is too uh two-dimensional
like what color is is is it brown tinted
is it black is it
uh like what's the theme is it a big
boar small board
are the uh what do the pawns look like
or is it more in the space of concepts
like uh
yeah the there are there aren't a lot of
colors it's mostly
so what is it queen's gambit on the
ceiling or whatever now
to imagine it what about when you do the
branching when you have multiple boards
and so on what how does that look are
you there's only one at a time so like
position in time one position at a time
so then i go back
and and that's what when when people
play
or at least that's what i do when i play
blindfold chess against several people
then it's just always one board at a
time and
the rest are stored away somewhere but
how do you store them away so like you
went down one branch you're like all
right that's i got that
i understand that that's there's some
good there there's some bad there now
let me go down another branch like how
do you store away the information you
just put on the shelf kind of
i i try and store it away sometimes i
have to sort of repeat it because i
forget
um and it does happen frequently in
games that
um
you're thinking for
especially if you're thinking for long
let's say half an hour or even more than
that that you play a move and then your
opponent plays a move then you play a
move and they play move again and you
realize oh
i actually calculated that i just forgot
about it
um so that's obviously what happens when
you store the information and you cannot
retrieve it when you think about a move
for 20 30 minutes
like how do you break that down
what can you describe what
like what's the algorithm here that
takes 30 minutes to run
30 minutes is uh
at least for me it's usually a waste um
30 minutes
usually means that i don't know what to
do
and i'm trying i'm just running into the
wall over here yeah i'm trying to find
something that isn't there i think
um 10 to 15 minutes things in
complicated positions can be really
really
uh helpful then you can
spend your time pretty
efficiently
just
it just means that
the branches are getting getting wider
so there's a lot to
um to run through
both in terms of calculation and lots
you have to evaluate as well and then
based on
based on that 10 to 15 minutes think you
you have a pretty good idea uh what to
what to do i mean it's it's very rare
that i would think for half an hour and
i would have a eureka moment
during the game like if i haven't seen
it in 10 minutes i'm probably not going
to see it at all you're going to
different branches yeah and like after
15 minutes it's like
mainly to the middle game because when
you get to the end game it's
usually brute force calculation that
makes you spend so much time so middle
game is
normally it's it's it's a complicated
mix of brute force calculation and and
uh and um
by creativity and and evaluation so end
game it's it's it's more it's it's
easier in that sense
you